ف تنبا
[Silence]
حميدا
الله اكبر
[Silence]
و
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم
الله قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم انا نشهد انك انت الله لا اله
الا انت الواحد الاحد الفرد الصمد الذي لم
يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد اللهم
اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت وتولنا
فيمن توليت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت وكنا
واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت انك تقضي ولا
يقضى عليك انه لا يذ واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر
لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم
تغفر لنا وترحمنا لكونن من
الخاسرين اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو
عناه اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو عنا
اللهم انك عفو
كريم تحب العفو فاعفو
عنا اللهم في ليلتي هذه مباركه لا تدع لنا
ذنبا الا غفرته ولا هما الا فرجته ولا
كربا الا
نفته ولا ميتا الا رحمته ولا اسيرا الا
يسرته ولا دينا الا
قضيته ولا مريضا الا
شافيته ولا عدوك الا احلقته ولا ضالا الا
هديته ولا اولادا الا اصلحته ولا حاجه من
حواء دنيا هي لك رضا ولنا قضيتها ويسرتها
لنا اللهم اعتق رقابنا من
النار ورقاب
والدينا
وذريتنا وازواج نا
وارحامنا
وامهاتنا
وابائنا
ومشائخنا
واخواننا واصحابنا وادخلنا جنه مع الابرار
يا عزيز يا
غفار اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم انصر دينك وكتابك
اللهم انصر نبيك سنه وسنه نبيك وعبادك
الصالحين اللهم ازل الشرك
والمشركين ودمر اعداء الدين يا قوي يا
عزيز اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق الفوض
ويا كاسيا عذام لحما بعد الموت اغفر لجميع
الموتى المسلمين الذين شهدك
بالوحدانيه والنبيك بالرساله
وماتوا على ذلك اللهم اغفر لهم
وارحمهم وعافهم وعفو عنهم واكرم نزلهم
ووسع مدخلهم واغسلهم بالماء ثلج والبرد
ونقيهم من الذنوب والخطايا كما ينقى الثوب
الابيد من
الدنس ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا وقواتنا
ابدا ما احييتنا واجعلهما وارث منا واجعل
ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من عادانا
ولا تسلط علينا بذنوبنا من لا يخافون فينا
ولا
يرحمنا اللهم تقبل صيامنا وتقبل
صلاتنا وتقبل زكاتنا وتقبل
قراننا
اللهم تقبل منا كل صالح
عمال اللهم تقبل قراننا في شهر هذا
المبارك اللهم اجعل له حجه لنا ولا حجه
علينا اللهم اللهم ذكرنا منه ما
نسينا وعلمنا منه ما جهلنا وارزقنا تلاوه
اناء الليل واطراف النهار على وجهك الذي
يرضيك عن النار
نار اللهم اصلح احوالنا واحوال المسلمين
اللهم اصلح بيوتنا وبيوت المسلمين اللهم
اسلح اولادنا واولاد المسلمين اللهم اسلح
امورنا وامور المسلمين ربنا تقبل منا انك
انت السميع العليم وتب علينا يا مولانا
انك انت التواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين
الله الله